state senator now running for North Las
Vegas mayor made an emotional statement
today as her son sits behind bars Pat
Spearman says her son 21 year old
nayanche Osborne was arrested after he
shot her nephew inside her home last
night it's NewsHour 8 news now
investigators broke this morning Sasha
Loftus joining us from the north Las
Vegas Community Correctional Center
after hearing from Spearman and her
family
state senator Pat Spearman said she
wanted to make it clear this incident is
not about politics and she will not be
dropping out of the Mayoral race now
another family member of hers also spoke
to us tonight about this incident this
has rattled me to the core an elected
official brought to tears after a
shooting within her own family is with a
heavy heart
that my family has impacted
by gun violence state senator and North
Las Vegas mayoral candidate Pat Spearman
says her son shot and hurt her nephew
David at her home on Thursday night she
just started screaming that it was my
older brother David's brother Julian
Davis says the situation has been
anything but easy and shared his
frustrations specifically with 21 year
old naomche Osborne arrested in
connection with the crime we all said
something like this is going to happen
if you don't do something to to help him
court records show Osborne has a history
with firearms and was ordered to
continue mental health counseling and
forfeit any guns he owned after a crime
in 2020. it's a really fit a device
between the large people of our family
now as David recovers Spearman says
she's grateful things weren't worse and
vows to stand behind whatever happens
next as a mother
I support both the justice system
and my son Osborne is facing multiple
charges including attempted murder
battery with a deadly weapon and firing
a gun into an unoccupied car or
structure reporting in North Las Vegas
tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now